कि नमस्कार जरूर सीखे हिंदी में कि
नेक्स्ट एपिसोड में आपका स्वागत है इसमें
कुछ एपिसोड से हम जर्मन में कंपलेक्स
स्ट्रक्चर कंपलेक्स सेंटेंस बनाना सीख रहे
हैं सबसे पहले हमने 10 साल सीखा प्रॉब्लम
ठीक है उसके बाद जो प्लस इंफिनिटिव सीखा
और इस संडे को बहुत इंपोर्टेंट एपिसोड है
उसमें उस पॉइंट है यह पॉइंट और सीखने वाले
मतलब क्या है कि आई दर और नॉट ओनली बट
अलसो उसको क्या बोलते हैं डरो डर के
संयोजन टर्नओवर हम सीखेंगे संडे को ओके
उसी चैनल में आज हमें छोटी सी कल से
ज्यादा यूज नहीं करते वह सीखने वाले हैं
वहीं रिलेटिव्स जिससे तुम्हे रिलेटिव्स व
क्या है तो अगर आप बोलोगे कि आप केदार वह
लड़का है जो क्रिकेट खेलता है तो अब हम
इन्हें भूलें ऐसे बोलते नहीं इलायची ये से
क्रिकेट खेलता है रंगरेज सीरियल उसे
इंग्लिश में क्या होगा किरदार इज द मैन हू
प्लेस क्रिकेट
कि संजय तिवारी द मैन हू प्लेस क्रिकेट
में कौन ऐसे बोलता है या फिर को बोलने
किरदार इज द मैन खून आए मिनट घुमाएंगे
करूंगा क्योंकि
एक तरफ कोई यथा समय सब्जेक्ट का किरदार इस
समय विकसित हो माई प्ले विद होम आईपीएल
गेहूं क्यों हुआ क्योंकि मिनट के बाद साइड
तो इसमें अगर आप देखोगे तो क्या किया हूं
वगैरह हमने किया वैसे ही इस कंसेप्ट को
जर्मन में बोलते रिलेटिव्स और उसके लिए हम
यूज करते हैं रिलेटिव प्रॉब्लम है रिलेटिव
प्रोनों में
तो फिर हमारे लिए अच्छी बात क्या है कि वह
जो प्रॉब्लम है न वह हम जो दक्षिणी यूज
करते थे वही है अगर आपको टेबल में वह देख
रहे होंगे तो इस सेशन का सबसे अच्छी बात
क्या है कि अगर आपकी केसेस अगर क्लियर है
तो आज आपको कुछ नया नहीं सीखना इस पिंपल
कुछ नया नहीं सीख रहे हो तो अगर आप देखोगे
स्टेबल में तो यह रिलेटिव अपॉइंटमेंट टेबल
जो है वह ऑलमोस्ट एक्जेक्टली आपके लिए
ट्यूमर की तरह है जो दल गठबंधन अगर आप
देखोगे दर्द हिंदी राशि डैम डैम सिर्फ एक
दिन था है और में दर्द देने पर लॉग इन
चीजों का टेंशन छोड़ दो कोई बात नहीं करता
है कि वह किरदार इज द मैन हुं बात करते
हैं सेंटेंस जस्ट कंप्लीटेड बट फर्स्ट ईयर
इंपोर्टेंट और वह रेडी कर दो
मैं तो ठीक हूं आप स्टेप बाय स्टेप हरेक
करके देखते हैं तो सबसे पहले नॉमिनेटिव
में देखते हैं कि इस समय नाखून प्लेट इधर
इस समय को प्ले लिस्ट तो एक चीज सिंपल
छोटी सी रखनी है कि जैसे वाइफ छाया धूप
लगे है यह ने झट से होते हैं और निबंध
मतलब क्या में सेंटेंस में तो का या
नार्मल सब्सक्राइब में
हैं पहला तो सिंपल है किरदार इस दा रुमाल
किरदार इस दौर में अधिकांश टक आएगा वही
यहां पर अपनी डिटेल में जाकर मेल और
नॉमिनेटिव मेल नॉमिनेट किया है इसीलिए
किरदार इस्ट धर्मानंद सब्सक्राइब क्या
होगा सब्सक्राइब का यह वैसे ही को
सबस्क्राइब subscribe and subscribe the
देखते हैं
में आ किरदार इज द मैन हू माई ट्वीट
घुमाया मिनट तो उसमें उसे घंटे में किरदार
क्या है आपको डेफिनेशन में हुआ तो क्या
होगा केदार इस अरमान कलेक्टर के आएगा आपको
ट्यूबवैल डेन डेन इस ट्रैक को
मैं आपको डिटेल में क्या वक्त ईमेल में
क्या होगा कविता इस तीव्र शूल इष्ट को
क्यों क्योंकि पॉजिटिव फीमेल लीड है से
मिलने को 2010 कैंट डांस ट्रैक को अगेन
आपको ट्यूब लाइट बंद स्थिर रखता है
क्योंकि कर लेते हैं केदार इस महल विधु
माई प्ले अगेन विद जर्मन में क्या है
मिट-मिट क्या होता है डोंट यू इसीलिए का
यह धार इस डर मांउट आबू में देखो डैम इस
अपील सिमिलरली टो विकास कविता इस दीप
फ्रॉम मीट ठेर स्किल अगर टाइपिंग मास्टर
होता है सिमिलरली टो बूस्ट 10 के 20 मिनट
डैम इश्क पिलर रेट अभी सिर्फ कंसेप्ट
क्लियर करने के कलाकार कंप्लीट करने के
लिए मैं
थे जेनिटिव का यह कदम पर आपको देता मगर को
बोलना यह भी किरदार इज द मैच पुरस्कार इस
रेड तो क्या होगा किरदार इस्तेमाल तो सेम
है अभी कॉल किया था तो उसमें से भून
इंग्लिश में भी वह थोड़ी देर नहीं टिक
करें तो जाकर ऊपर देखो क्या है 10 पर है
डिफिकल्ट हाउ टो रोटेट के अनुसार इस दिन
थे सिस्टम टो रोटेट थे सिंपलेस्ट बट इन
थिस व्यक्ति कभी Bigg Boss ने करने वाले
हो कि केंद्र वह आदमी है जिसकी गाड़ी लाल
है जिसकी घड़ी लाल सब्सक्राइब अगर आपको
लगता है कि आपको यह भी याद रखने की जरूरत
नहीं आता है तो इसे सब्सक्राइब चेंज करनी
है क्योंकि अगर आपको यह है कि इस यौन
क्विट स्किल्ड इस घोड़े न अभी एक छोटी सी
कंसेप्ट और है अंकुश व न रिलेटिव झट से वह
मतलब कवर करता हूं पर आपको यह देखो
क्योंकि अपने आप को डेढ़ लाइट मैं थोड़ी
सी लगती है वह लड़का जो क्रिकेट खेलता है
केदार सेट अभी बात करोगे तो सामने वाला
क्या समझेंगे के लिए क्या बात कर रहा है
इंग्लिश में भी द मैन हू प्लेस क्रिकेट
इसके अंदर आप ऐसे नहीं बात करते हो राइट
तो जर्मन में वैसे आप नॉर्मल नहीं बात
करोगे बट उल्टा जस्ट प्लेयर्स रतन सेट
कैसे होगा यह दरमान फिर मैं दो जितने
पदार्थ इसी बीच में आएगा
नई दिल्ली क्रिकेट स्पिल्ट इस्ट किरदार
निर्माण दैनिक प्रिंटेड सलवार कम समय में
ही आप खुद से यह कभी नहीं यूज करोगे बट
जस्ट सपोज आपने कभी एग्जाम में यह अभी
डिलीट में से कुछ देखा तो आपको पता होना
चाहिए कि दूर दो बार देर क्यों है तो
बेसिकली मैं इसको बीच में डाल दिए बट एसिड
थिस कंटेस्ट इन जनरल आईएस नॉट मच यूज्ड
100 बट इट्स गुड टो नो व्हाय हो कि आप सब
तो यह कनेक्ट समझ में आए होगी इस संडे हम
बहुत इंपोर्टेंट कंसेप्ट जैसे मैंने बोला
सीखने वाले हैं स्वान टेलिकॉम सेक्टर हैंड
हम मिलते हैं उस कंडीशन में धन्यवाद